[Música]
iniciábamos google juicio contra el
líder opositor alexéi navalni la
petición del servicio penitenciario que
pide hacer efectiva la pena suspendida
de tres años y medio de prisión a la que
fue condenada en 2014 por fraude
comercial y blanqueo de capitales
alegando incumplimiento en la libertad
condicional
un día después del golpe de estaban y
anmar el partido de la nobel de paz aún
san suu kyi exigió al ejército su
liberación inmediata y la de todos los
líderes civiles detenidos también exigió
respeto por los resultados de las
elecciones generales de noviembre la
comunidad internacional continúa
rechazando este golpe
poderosa nevada azota el noreste de eeuu
miles de vuelos cancelados escuelas
cerradas y la vacunación temporalmente
suspendida son algunos de los estragos
de esta tormenta el servicio
meteorológico nacional emitió una alerta
de tormenta para los estados afectados y
el temporal de invierno irá hasta mañana
miércoles
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros entradas 24 se redoblan
concurso saludarlos comenzamos en rusia
donde inició en moscú el juicio al líder
opositor alexéi navalni a petición del
servicio federal penitenciario que
demanda a ser efectiva en la pena
suspendida de tres años y medio de
prisión a la que éste fue condenado en
el año 2014 en diciembre de ese año en
aval nin fue condenado por un caso de
fraude en un juicio que en 2017 fue
calificado de arbitrario por el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos sin embargo
el servicio federal penitenciario le
acusa haber incumplido los términos de
libertad condicional cuando estaba en
alemania recuperándose del
envenenamiento que sufrió en siberia en
agosto del año pasado según el kremlin
sería un insensatez de la unión europea
condicione sus relaciones con rusia
dependiendo de lo que suceda con naval y
vamos a moscú donde previamente
conversamos con nuestro corresponsal
xavier colás y nos junto como el juicio
y que se espera para hoy veamos
bueno pues el juicio ha empezado y tras
una pausa se acaba de reanudar hace
pocos minutos existe la esposa de nava y
giuliana que fue detenida brevemente
durante las protestas del pasado domingo
en estos momentos el argumento de la
acusación es precisamente ese demostrar
que naval de incumplió los términos de
esa especie de libertad condicional que
estaba disfrutando y no se presentó a
los controles periódicos así lo ha
relatado un funcionario de prisiones a
lo que el propio naval ni ha contestado
no podía documentar el lugar en el que
me encontraba porque yo mismo estaba en
coma no obstante la defensa de naval ni
ha insistido en que aunque nadal y no
contestó a las autoridades
penitenciarias sí que estuvo en contacto
en todo momento el abogado de naval ni
que es ahora mismo quien le está
defendiendo en este juicio para evitar
que el opositor vuelva a prisión al
cumplir una pena que podría estar en
torno a tres años porque habría que
descontarle diez meses de arresto
domiciliario que cumplió en el pasado
y un día después del golpe de estado en
mi armar el ejército sigue firmemente
instalado en el poder y mantiene bajo
arresto a la líder del país shan sang
soo choo la acción militar ha causado
una ola de condenas internacionales de
gobierno y ongs su chip instó a sus
seguidores a protestar en una carta
escrita antes de su detención veamos el
siguiente informe
la vida vuelve a las calles de rangún
mientras los residentes se abastecen de
comida en un mercado local con poca
presencia militar a la vista los bancos
han abierto y las conexiones telefónicas
e internet han vuelto aunque la
incertidumbre está en el aire este
taxista no ha tenido un solo cliente en
todo el día
eduard a fumar incluso durante la
pandemia mis ganancias no han sufrido
gran impacto pero ahora las cosas han
dado un giro repentino con la situación
política actual la gente tiene miedo a
salir de esta ruta al aeropuerto
internacional de la ciudad ha sido
cerrada por los militares que parecen
tener el control firme desde el golpe
del lunes el ejército ya ha reemplazado
a 11 ministros y diputados y ha
declarado el estado de emergencia el
paradero de la ley de mianmar aún
sanssouci no está claro fuentes de su
partido liga nacional para la democracia
dicen que está bajo arresto domiciliario
en su residencia oficial mientras tanto
se tiene entendido que cientos de
parlamentarios están recluidos en
viviendas gubernamentales de la capital
para la ong human rights watch las
acciones del ejército son
golpe para la transición del país
el gran temor ahora es por supuesto que
todas las personas que hablaron en
contra de los militares a lo largo de
los años durante la democracia tengan
que esconderse porque podrían enfrentar
represalias
el golpe se produce después de que el
ejército se negara a aceptar los
resultados de las elecciones de
noviembre que dieron al partido de aung
san suu si una victoria aplastante el
ejército la acusó de fraude algo que fue
negado por la comisión electoral del
país
el rechazo internacional luego del golpe
estaba mi amar no para la secretaria de
prensa de la casa blanca afirmó que la
declaración del presidente de byd en
sobre el golpe militar en ese país
asiático está dirigida a todas las
naciones de la región y reafirmó su
oposición a cualquier intento de alterar
el resultado de esas elecciones son para
ir a una transición democrática por su
parte el canciller de corea del sur
pidió la liberación inmediata de la
liberad sant xotxim y otros funcionarios
elegidos democráticamente mientras que
el ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de china dijo antes de una reunión del
consejo de seguridad de la onu que todas
las acciones de la comunidad
internacional deben contribuir a la
estabilidad política y social de mianmar
para evitar crecientes tensiones nuestro
corresponsal en beijing adrián foncillas
con los detalles de la posición del
gigante asiático
sin ha pedido esfuerzos de
reconciliación y que se asegure la
estabilidad social y económica del país
es la previsible respuesta aséptica
china que responde a su innegociable
principio de no injerencia en asuntos
externos y que contrasta con el coro
condenatorio y las peticiones de
sanciones de occidente china además en
este caso guarda excelentes relaciones
con ambos bandos fue uno de los pocos
países que no dio la espalda a mianmar
durante los 50 años de gobierno militar
y esos lazos han quedado fortalecidos
desde que subió al poder ansa
a pesar de que se había especulado con
que la dama que había sido referenciada
por occidente podría mitigar la
influencia china lo cierto es que a
china y a mianmar les unen intereses
económicos como el petróleo y el gas mi
alma es clave en la nueva ruta de la
seda el proyecto estrella del presidente
de sí sin fin con iniciativas tan
relevantes como la construcción de una
nueva línea de ferrocarril de más de 9
mil millones de dólares que unirá la
costa oeste birmana con la provincia
china de yunnan
cambiamos ahora información un manto de
nieve con acumulaciones que podrían
llegar hasta los 60 centímetros cubre la
costa este de eeuu esto ha llevado a
algunos estados de esta zona a suspender
la vacunación contra el cob y 19 se
trata de un temporal con consecuencias
en la política el histórico nombramiento
de alejandro mayorkas como el primer
latino al frente del departamento de
seguridad nacional se aplazó no son
cuentas hwan pupiales
es un golpe de nieve una tormenta que
paraliza la costa este de eeuu la región
del país con mayor densidad de población
son zonas con una acumulación de nieve
que se estima estará entre 31 y 61
centímetros es desde pensilvania sammen
en donde el fenómeno climático ha
golpeado con más fuerza según el
servicio de meteorología y es la gran
manzana uno de los puntos de mayor
afectación
algunas personas tienen un lugar en
donde quedarse otras no lo mejor que se
puede hacer es intentar sobrevivir en
las calles más del 90% de los vuelos en
la ciudad de nueva york se cancelaron
pero lo que más preocupa es la
suspensión de la vacunación es algo que
se registra en el estado y la ciudad de
nueva york además de nueva jersey y
massachusetts datos todo esto es la
tormenta está afectando nuestro esfuerzo
de vacunación y necesitamos mantener a
salvo a la gente no queremos vecinos
especialmente adultos mayores
saliendo bajo condiciones inseguras para
vacunarse sabemos que podemos reagendar
la cita es muy rápido porque claro
tenemos nuestro suministro
las consecuencias de la nieve llegan
hasta la política la confirmación de
alejandro mayorkas nacido en cuba se
tuvo que aplazar en el senado y con ella
su entrada en la historia como el primer
latino al frente del departamento de
seguridad nacional bajo la
administración de joe biden también se
tuvo que suspender un discurso del
presidente previsto para el lunes en el
que el mandatario pretendía detallar sus
prioridades en política exterior un
incendio forestal al oeste de la ciudad
australiana de perth ha destruido una
treintena de edificios obligado a
evacuar a miles de personas en pleno
confinamiento por la pandemia de kobe 19
según indicó el departamento de bomberos
el fuego unido a los fuertes vientos que
azota de esta región ha aumentado en las
últimas horas el gobernador regional
afirmó que su territorio estaba
afrontando en este momento dos
emergencias muy diferentes los incendios
y el confinamiento decretado por un
brote de coronavirus
y cambiamos nuevamente información haití
vive hoy su segundo día de huelga para
denunciar el clima de inseguridad la
violencia y el importante aumento de los
casos de secuestro en todo el territorio
en los últimos meses a esto se suma el
llamado de la oposición y otros
movimientos o manifestaciones para
exigir la salida del presidente yo en el
móvil quien ha reiterado que su mandato
finaliza el 7 de febrero pero 2022 al
asegurar que fue elegido para un periodo
de cinco años y no de cuatro como dice
la oposición y que se cumplirá el
próximo domingo el mandatario cuenta con
el respaldo de la oea nuestra compañía
desde puerto príncipe
gotson pierre analista y periodista
director de la plataforma alterpresse
alter heart dio gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros señor pierre varios puntos
que analizar en este momento el primero
que es lo que está llevando al aumento
de los secuestros en el país y si tiene
un tinte político esta problemática
pero qué
es una cosa muy complicada porque a
veces al final del año observamos
casos de secuestro pero esta vez son
muchos desde el fin de 2020 y al inicio
de este año
constatamos que hay muchos muchos casos
de
de secuestros
varias informaciones salieron de las
organizaciones de defensa de derechos
humanos para acercar a la criminalidad
con
en motivos políticos
casi siempre con una relación con el
gobierno está en el poder ahora es por
eso que dicen estos casos de secuestros
tienen un sentido político si ahora el
segundo punto es el mandato del
presidente de las elecciones de 2015
fueron anuladas por denuncias de fraude
y repetidas en 2016 moix asumió en 2017
para un período de cinco años pero la
oposición argumenta que son cuatro años
porque se adelantó el inicio del periodo
presidencial cuando termina realmente el
mandato del presidente
la constitución de haití dice que cuando
las elecciones se retrasan el mandato
presidencial empieza el año de las
elecciones el año de las elecciones fue
2016 y entonces a pesar de que el
presidente empezó su mandato como tal
toma función en 2010 17 sorprendido es
reputado
haber empezado desde el 7 febrero de
2016 es por esto basándose sobre la
constitución dicen que el mandato
presidencial va a terminarse el 7 de
febrero de 2021 y sobre eso también hay
un aviso que es un aviso de todos todas
las mesas de abogados en el país que
dice la misma cosa ahora el señor pie
cuáles son los puntos que plantea la
posición para pedir la renuncia de moix
y
realmente no piden ahora
la renuncia de inmovilizar que antes
durante los meses antes pidieron la
renuncia de los de luís pero ahora
abogan para que respeta la ley respeta
la constitución la constitución dicen es
el mismo documento para todo el mundo y
yo en el mois el mismo y aplicó la ley
de la constitución para reducir de un
año a 12 años los mandatos de los
senadores de 10 senadores al inicio de
2019 ahora piden que yon de luisa aplica
la misma ley para el mismo
señor gotson pierre gracias por su
tiempo y por supuesto por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 en una próxima
oportunidad quinto día de visita en
wuhan china del equipo de expertos de la
organización mundial de la salud que
investiga los orígenes del coach 19 el
día de hoy visitaron el centro de
enfermedades animales de hebei y al
regresar a su hotel se vio llegar a un
convoy que transportaba a funcionarios
chinos el equipo independiente ya visitó
hospitales clave el centro regional de
control de enfermedades y el mercado de
mariscos de la ciudad de wuhan donde se
cree que se originó el primer grupo de
infecciones a finales de 2019
hasta que el informativo feliz día
[Música]
france24